before we go into the actual conflict of
the Korean War let's try to get a sense
of the the historical environment going
into the Korean War so if you go all the
way back to the late 1800s Early 1900s
the Korean Peninsula what we now
consider both North and South Korea they
were occupied by the Japanese military
and then in 1910 in 1910 the the Korean
Peninsula is formally annexed into the
Japanese Empire so the Japanese are
essentially this colonial this
imperialist power here and they stay in
power in the Korean Peninsula all the
way until the end of World War two and
it's probably worth saying here it's
probably worth making doing a bunch of
videos here that the the Japanese
occupation was not a pleasant occupation
for the Korean people they subjugated
the Korean people in multiple ways
forced labor forced prostitution of they
tried to kind of eradicate the Korean
language in the Korean culture so this
was not in any way a pleasant occupation
they weren't pleasant imperialists but
you fast-forward all the way to 1945 we
know that Japan loses World War two and
the major two victors on the Allied side
that are kind of acting in this part of
the world are the United States and the
Soviet Union and so 1945 you have the
Soviets coming from above
you have the Soviets coming from above
that's the Soviets coming from above and
eventually you have the Americans coming
from below they occupy Japan first so
this is the USA and they essentially
remember at this point even though this
is kind of the beginning of the Cold War
at this point in World War two the
United States and the Soviet Union are
allies and so United States kind of
tells the Soviet Union hey why don't we
just stop at the 38th parallel why don't
we just stop at the 38th parallel in the
United States actually didn't even think
that the Soviets would stop there but
they actually did and from the Soviets
point of view it's believed that they
stopped there because the United States
didn't get there at the same time so
there was no one to stop them from going
further south but it's believed that the
Soviets wanted to uphold their side of
the agreement so that they could get you
know so that they would be a trusted
party in the negotiations in Europe and
maybe get more in Europe which is what
the Soviets
maybe cared about more so what happens
after World War two is that the north
what's now North Korea essentially
becomes under the influence of the
Soviets everything below the 38th
parallel becomes under the influence of
the United States
the Soviets essentially install this
gentleman right over here to lead North
Korea Kim Milson or the part of Korea
that is north of the 38th parallel at
this point this was just kind of viewed
as a point where the Soviets the United
States should kind of meet up where they
would have to stop it wasn't meant to be
an actual partition of the country but
as we'll see it actually becomes a
partition of the country but the Soviets
install Kim il-sung he sets up a
communist essentially a communist
dictator dictatorship in the north and
this is the current leader of North
Korea's dad this is Kim Jong Il's dad
so he gets installed in the north and in
the south if you fast forward a little
bit to 1948 there is an attempt at
elections but those attend those
elections are seriously rigged and this
gentleman Sigmund recover and although
he might look like a nice Pleasant man
he was actually fairly ruthless and he
is
you know unanimously considered a strong
man and on both sides of this once again
this is one of those situations where
you really can't call either of these
guys good guys because both of them are
have have done some pretty nasty nasty
things to each other to two soldiers on
either side and and to innocent
civilians but syngman rhee comes to
power in the south and his I guess most
attractive feature to the Americans is
that he is not is that he is not a
communist and so you have this situation
setting up communist north above 30th
parallel non-communist South controlled
by Sigmund Rhee supported by the United
States the other thing that happens is
that the Soviets help build up the North
Korean military the United States is not
as encouraging of a strong South Korean
military so you start having an
imbalance between the military of the
north and the south and obviously either
one of these parties Kim il-sung wants
to unite Korea under his rule under his
communist rule syngman rhee wants to
wants to unite Korea under his
authoritarian rule so they're both kind
of sending setting up
troops they're both setting up troops
along the border and this whole time
this whole time you have skirmishes
going on across the border and just to
give you a context you're probably
saying wait Korea's you know right next
to China what was going on there and if
you go to China you in 1949 the
Communists come to power there was a
civil war leading up to that between the
Communists led by Mao say Tung and the
Nationalists led by Chiang kai-shek Mao
Zedong comes to power he wants to
support the the Communists in North
Korea especially because some of those
communists in North Korea actually
helped helped fight the helped fight on
the Communist side during the Chinese
Civil War so this is an important factor
right here Mao Zedong is interested in
spreading communism he doesn't like the
Americans in South Korea and he feels
some type of allegiance to the
Communists in North Korea so now you
fast forward to June 25th 1950 and in
the North you have a major embed that
there's a lot the north at the North
Korean army it's not called North Korea
at this point they both considers
themselves Korea competing I guess
governments of Korea the the army in the
north is disproportionately stronger
than the south and so they invade they
view this as their chance at unifying
the peninsula and essentially they're
able to almost just kind of storm
through the Korean Peninsula immediately
when that happens the UN and especially
the United States then this is because
at this point the Soviet Union was
boycotting the Security Council so they
couldn't even veto it the UN immediately
starts supplying naval and air support
for the South Koreans but regard the
disparity is so big that the North
Koreans are able to just keep marching
keep marching forward within a few days
literally by July 1st the United States
descends decides to commit ground forces
because we had substantial ground forces
in Japan which isn't that far away just
to give you a global perspective this is
the Korean Peninsula right here and this
is Japan and I could have probably found
a bigger picture of that but America had
military forces in Japan that they could
send and so the Americans enter the
force in a
enter the battle in a major way very
early on but that doesn't stop the North
Koreans for some time so the North
Koreans get all the way they're able to
occupy all of the Korean Peninsula
except for kind of the north eastern
corner so they get they get around this
far and so over here you have the city
of Pusan and this is called the Pusan
Perimeter Pusan Perimeter and it's at
the Pusan Perimeter that you have a
little bit of a of a the United States
and Korean forces combined are able to
halt the North Koreans and you have a
kind of a slight stalemate for a couple
of months here but that while that
stalemate is happening the United States
is able to and especially the UN but
it's mainly the United States is able to
build up significant troops within
within the Pusan Perimeter but even more
and at this point and at this point the
United States and the UN forces go under
the control of Douglas MacArthur General
Douglas MacArthur who's a bit of an
interesting character and till this
point he was able to kind of rule Japan
with an iron fist
he's hugely popular war hero in America
and the current President Truman kind of
has little trouble controlling MacArthur
especially during the Korean War and
we'll see that MacArthur really
overstepped his bounds during the course
of this war now at this point you have
the South Koreans and the Americans kind
of cornered out down here inside the
Pusan Perimeter it looks like North
Korea's on the verge of victory but the
u.s. is able to build forces and the
Korean War really just starts becoming
into a game of risk I don't know if
you've ever played the game of Risk but
whenever it's somebody's turn they're
able to spread their forces but then
they get spread thin and then the other
side is able to come back and we'll see
is the rest of the Korean War is
essentially a back and forth between the
Communists in the north supported by the
Chinese although the Chinese aren't in
the war officially just yet and then the
Americans in the south and the first
really smart thing that MacArthur does
is he says look instead of trying to
fight our way through the Korean forces
that are over here instead of trying to
fight our way through all of these
Korean forces that are over here why
don't we just kind of outflank them and
why don't we use our naval our Navy to
do an amphibious
landing of an army at Incheon so in
September 15th while you have kind of
the stalemate over here the United
States they have an amphibious landing
so they send troops from all of these
places they have an infamous landing at
Inchon which is near Seoul so they land
right over they land at Incheon which is
roughly over there I'm not super
accurate here and what's interesting
about that is in any battle all of these
Korean troops right here they have
supply chains they have to get food and
supplies and fresh troops from up here
and so the further in you go into enemy
territory the more spread out your
troops get and the strategies here is
instead of fighting through this what if
we outflank them and are able to land a
significant force right here and
immediately disrupt the supply lines of
the North Koreans and that's exactly
that's essentially what the Americans
did and it was successful so MacArthur
looks like a genius over here and he's
able to retake Seoul he's able to take
the what's kind of the North Korean
capital at this point Pyongyang and you
have the Americans marching north so all
of a sudden it started off with the
North Koreans being able to roll down
and now all of a sudden the Americans
and the South Koreans are able to roll
up and they're feeling pretty good about
themselves and the whole time
Truman's trying to keep MacArthur under
check MacArthur's excited he's ultra
confident he thinks that the the troops
are going to be home by Christmas
he doesn't think China is serious about
about supporting North Koreans and even
more he almost it seems like wants to
pick a fight with China because he wants
to maybe maybe eliminate communism in
China as well he view'd is you know he's
kind of on this mission to eliminate
communism from all of Asia so Truman is
saying limited war don't cross the Yalu
River and and and be careful don't don't
you know don't start attacking Chinese
up here and enrage them and and you're
going to have them you know enter the
war MacArthur is it doesn't take that
too seriously and he also says look I
have to start bombing bombs across the
Yalu River so that the Chinese won't be
able to send won't be able to send
troops and supplies to aid the North
Koreans so he's marching up all
confident going up against the Yalu
River and this whole time the Chinese
under Mao Satan
under Mao Satan are sending a pretty
substantial army and they're able to do
it secretly they're able to march at
night and they even have these policies
where if any surveillance planes go
overhead all of the Chinese soldiers
have to freeze and if they don't freeze
someone else is allowed to shoot them so
everyone wants to freeze so that no one
can really see them from above so it's
this really kind of a secret buildup of
troops across the Yalu River and this
whole time MacArthur is just ultra ultra
confident about what's happening over
here but then you fast forward until the
end of October the Americans think that
they're on the verge of winning the
Korean War and all of a sudden you have
the Chinese cross the Yellow River and
the Americans didn't even know that the
Chinese had major forces ready to cross
so now you have the and once again it's
just like a game of Risk so now you have
the Chinese cross they catch the
Americans unsuspected they engage a few
times the Americans weren't sure if the
Chinese were serious so they keep re
engaging them but then it becomes clear
yes the Chinese are serious
the Chinese are serious and essentially
the Chinese are able to push back the
Americans and the South Koreans all the
way back so that they're able to
recapture Seoul but once again like any
game of Risk now the Chinese are spread
thin the the Americans and the South
Koreans and all the you other UN forces
although the UN forces are mainly the
Americans are able to regroup are able
to regroup and then in march so Seoul
has changed and four times so in march
they're able to retake Seoul again
they're able to retake Seoul again and
at this point MacArthur you know ultra
confident he's telling the Chinese
you've essentially lost he's even trying
to get permissions to use nuclear
weapons against the Chinese he to some
degree he doesn't even think he needs
the permission of Truman to stop it
sounds like he's eager to push the
Chinese further back even though they
kind of surprised him the first
go-around so Truman has enough of this
of this wildcard guy who you know thinks
that he can call the shots and use
nuclear weapons if he wants to
willy-nilly and so Truman finally
dismisses MacArthur in April in April of
1951 and at this point you start having
a stalemate you have you start having a
stalemate near the 38th parallel so that
you start having a stalemate across
this border right over there and both
sides think the end of the war is
imminent they're like okay we're back to
where we both began we should both stop
here but the negotiations unfortunately
took over two years and there's a lot of
I guess back and forth about what to do
with prisoners of war and all of the
rest but it finally took two years so
that in July 20 27 1953 you have an
armistice signed between the two parties
and I want to make it clear and our
mistress that an armistice agreement it
is not a peace treaty it's not saying
that we both agree that this is the
border of our two new countries and that
we are now at peace with each other all
an armistice means is that we're going
to stop fighting it is not a formal end
to the war so in theory in theory North
and South Korea even to this day are in
a state of war and you know to this day
I'm recording this video in 2011 maybe
if you view this in the future hopefully
they won't be in a official state of war
but they're an official state of war
under an armistice they've just agreed
they've just agreed to stop fighting so
all in all you have this hugely bloody
battle with all of these atrocities
going on in both sides you know syngman
rhee when he was the first time when the
North Korean troops were rolling in to
South Korea he essentially beforehand he
was he was kind of imprisoning a bunch
of people who he suspected to be
communists and when he said when I'm
talking about people I'm talkin bout
whole families sometimes and when he was
recruiting he essentially allowed the
massacre of a huge number of people who
are just suspected of being communists
and you know these weren't just military
men these were women these were children
these were entire families so he's
guilty of that and Kim il-sung
just as guilty when when the North
Korean soldiers infiltrated the South
Korea and Seoul they committed
atrocities killing civil servants
killing any of the kind of established
intellectuals in the area so on both
sides this hugely horrific war and just
to get a sense of what was happening you
know Korea isn't a huge country but you
have within Korea the civilian debts 1.5
to 3 million civilian debts and the
consensus is at 2 million and you know
this tells you how ugly war is is that
you can't even estimate how many people
die to the nearest you know 500,000
people you just don't know what happened
but to
million people died in a country that's
not too big you have 30 you know all in
all you have about 40,000 American
soldiers dying
China China losses on the order of
depending on the estimates 400,000
soldiers I mean the estimates are all
over the place North Korea losses on the
order same magnitude of soldiers South
Korea losses you know several hundred
thousands of soldiers so you have this
hugely bloody battle this hugely bloody
war I should say that really ends with a
outcome that wasn't so different from
where it started